Wow.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina,
cause it's interesting.
Okay.
We listened to them though. I
liked it. We followed his advice.
We did UBI.
They're amazing
in my left ear there to switching.
Yeah.
I think it's just a loose wire somewhere,
right?
I can unplug it. No, no, no. Oh,
I thought you were going to tell
it to torture now. It's good. Yeah.
This song is called TV Mike.
Check by lady money.
That was the most mind
numbing video I've ever seen.
Regulating money.
You already
made a whole song. It is. It's
really good. Good. I know. Sure.
Hi.
Hey man,
we got it.
So good.
Sound
quality. What we've heard in here is a
world, a world apart, a world different.
We've been talking in a tin
cans up until now. I know.
We still have no official.
I can hear every smell in your beard
through this microphone. It's very funny.
We still have native on a Shitty Shure sm.
Seven birds don't get good. Mike's, yeah.
Oh yeah.
He's upset.
Native American native American bird.
Oh that's right.
Blue bands aren't native Americans. Right.
That's the whole point. I was making Oh,
blue in a native American bird.
Right. He's still on the shore.
Quiet bird.
Um,
not really.
Are you on Mike?
Now it's quiet.
Is that what went out?
Maybe that was the talk into a
native. Yeah, I can hear you. Yeah,
you have to be close. All right. Um,
thank you to everybody that
came out to a voice is so loud.
Now you're on California.
Five sold out shows. Hey,
now
mother of Fox.
We're going to pause this and we're back.
Um,
again.
Shit.
Third Time's a charm.
Yeah.
So this week I am in a Gash
Shrill Tennessee at xannies.
Tickets are flying. Saturday's
already sold out. Um,
I'm there Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
Xannies and Gaskell Tennessee.
Um,
the following week,
Wes nut sack New York.
So my mom, um, I've never been there.
You've been there, right? It's actually,
it's really fun. It's a great
club. Levity, live levity,
live. It's a huge realm.
You're going to like it. Yeah.
And I don't know if there's an,
I hop in that mall and I know you
like your eye hot. I have my Syracuse.
Well, smear my juice. [inaudible] juice,
um,
after that spitting her nasty Ohio,
it's good.
Um,
fit in her is Cincinnati.
Yeah.
You only get,
you just kinda like,
yeah.
Well actually somebody put yeah, spit
on her nasty. I like, that's better.
That's better. Yeah. Okay. No, I
approved, continued on her nasty.
Um,
then I have
San Diego. Yeah. Um, oh.
So it's been on her ass.
He was July seven through
nine, man, Diego, seven 14.
So July 14 to 16,
a Saint Louis tits.
St Louis. Great. July 21 through 23,
uh,
come on our bus,
Ohio on August 11th.
Hey, come on. Our bus.
Did you pork titties?
Always my baron.
September eight 10 in New York City
at Caroline's and fill her pelvis up.
Pork, Sylvania. Uh, that is November 18th,
because November 19th sold out.
Thank you everybody.
Thomson [inaudible] Dot com go
to the shows page for tickets.
Genes. Okay, Mike. So,
okay. Uh, June 19th,
I met sperm bank at flip comedy clubs.
5:00 PM show, believe it or not. Wow.
You moved it from the u
who ended the main room.
If you want to come see me run lower,
it's move that room very famous.
Then the 22nd I'm at Melrose,
the Improv comedy club.
Come to that one if you will, on the 22nd.
It's kind of an important show for me.
I'd appreciate support.
I can't say what it is,
but just know it's a big show
business. Um, and then, okay,
here's my tours.
My One nighters,
September 27th I'm in meat
rattle. Is that okay? Yeah.
Amit rattled Tacoma to come on you to
come on you comedy club ands Yad tits.
What's meet rattled. See, it's
not even good as what Seattle?
Uh, I don't remember.
And I remember. Okay. Uh,
the 28th I am in Portland. Yep. Portland,
Oregon at helium comedy
club a minute. Horrigan. Oh,
that's really good.
Yeah. Portland, Oregon,
nine 28 and then a October 4th and Dallas,
which is eat my ass,
eat my ass to Haas.
And then October 5th, Houston,
Euston, Houston, Houston,
Houston, God. Ever since we have blue
van, Jew jokes are really coming.
We never used to, I didn't know
how to spot make as many. Yeah,
it was the whole thing is
he taught me how to spot it.
October 5th in Houston.
Go to thousand ranch.com.
That's thousand ranch.com for tickets.
I'd appreciate it if he came out.
Also guys, uh, you shop on Amazon.
I know you do because you're smart and
you don't like to leave your house the
way Tom and I are rec loses. Please
use our banner. Go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom of the
homepage and just do your shopping as
you normally would. Just kicks
back a little change to the show
with the was, uh, like that. Uh, yeah,
it was really good.
Is that your raps?
That's one of my better than
nick hockey rapping. Actually.
I am and I've never wrapped and I'm
still better. Uh, working up a sweat.
Sweating. I'm breaking a sweat. I'm
breaking it up. Set it is all broken.
A sweat
so bad.
Are you ready to do your thing and
stuff like that? Stuff like that.
Are you ready? I'm ready. Let's
party. Yeah, let's go guys,
let's go get your lives too.
Together.
Why doesn't it go over
to the screen? Oh, bye.
What do you mean,
why is it here?
Why doesn't it pop up there?
Got It.
Drag it over.
No, my last week I just hit it and
it would just open up there. Oh,
maybe cause like, have you restarted
computers inside and it's like that.
That's weird. Okay. All right. I
messed up this one. I'm sorry. Got It.
All right. You Ready? Tom Saucy. He
had three bowel movements this morning.
Let's go.
All
right.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh, okay. I see.
Why are you copycatting?
I hired her
first. I came in with a full bottle.
There was already been decided by the way,
by the listeners and viewers of this
show that I'm the water champ. Bullshit.
Yeah. I saw a lot of posts. Nobody
said anything. Everybody said it.
Everybody says if you probably watch
the back episodes of your mom's house,
you'll notice that I drank so much more
water than my husband. I constantly,
I have multiple look multiple
containers next to me.
[inaudible] backup waters.
I point look was in the tiny fridge.
Just in case I get thirsty during a show
message. What are you doing? You
playing your honesty in a fee. Uh,
she questioned my water intake
one down.
It's stupid.
Second one.
That wasn't even yours. That was probably
the Dobbs. Who's that? Blue bands
native. And that's a trick.
That's a stunt water.
You can drill the hole in it
and there's a tube and drinking.
He's was a leader. I drink more
water than you. That's not true.
I sweat more than you. Not True. Not True.
Not True. Not true close.
Yup. I'm the water champion.
There you go. Hi. Bird is fat.
You know what? I bet if you and
I all the hello. Hey everybody.
Everybody says,
everyone says time you drink more water.
I bet if we went to urinate right now,
you and me and separate toilets and
look to mind will be clearer. Therefore,
denoting I drink more water than
you. Yours is dark brown. Well,
I bet if we both,
uh,
jumped on a broom and we went for a
flight that we could both see different
things and talk to it makes no sense
because mine is yours. No, it does.
I know this because I hydrate a lot,
but when you drink more water,
the clearer your everybody's dupes.
Everybody knows that.
You know that when you're four,
well then you don't know that because
your a is brown. No, it's like coffee,
like all the dirty coffee and your
teeth, Matt. Sure. Your liquidity.
You're so rude.
This lady in this video looks like Yo,
I love
[inaudible]
cause the best,
the reaction. Yeah, he's phenomenal.
Now what I love is that we had suck my
pussy, which was the wells Fargo Bank.
Ladies, I'm sorry. Kiss my pussy.
Happy you confuse those and now
suck my pussy on a bloody day.
Those are two really exciting,
very ordinary,
extraordinary public versions.
One in a bank
and one on the train. I like
that. I'm on kiss my pussy.
She goes, you beg of America,
you Chinese motherfucker.
Shit. She's the best. The
best part is she goes,
I got $1 million in this bank.
Half a million, half a million,
half a million is motherfucker.
As a matter of fact, we
don't have it queued up.
Why? How can black women are so
good at insults? What is that?
It's gotta be genetic.
I guess.
They're so good at that stuff, man.
They are all of them. Absolutely.
Black woman will crush you anytime
verbally. They're very good. That's true.
I went to public school in La.
I was on. This is not happening.
Look up the story in a trawl.
Yeah.
Rosina Johnson. She could spit some
shit like that too. Yeah, that's true.
I don't know man. I don't think maybe
you've experienced it more than I have.
Yeah. You mean black women haven't
yelled at you a lot? Not really.
That's a girl thing about black guys.
You got stories of you yelling black
dude. I've been, I've had some shit.
Talk to me for sure.
Public School in Milwaukee,
Florida. There's a lot of shit talking.
Yeah, just this part of the culture.
The best part of living in New York City
is that everything happens in public.
There is no private cause you just,
you have to do everything in public.
There's so many people that you see this
stuff every day. Of course. So good.
Are you finding kiss my pussy?
I think so. We'll see if we can.
We'll see
it is wells Fargo.
I got half a million in this motherfucker.
$40.
She's really scary.
I've got these keys on my waist to
a shit.
Oh my God. Yeah. Suck my pussy
and kiss my pussy. Yeah. Good job.
Good job on a bloody day.
Friday night and be back.
I Want my God.
Yeah,
you bet.
She,
you bank of America,
you're in wells Fargo,
Chinese mother fuckers.
None of it makes sense
up to the people in line that I got.
Why don't you love if this was
a commercial for Wells Fargo?
This would be the best
commercials all the time. No,
it would be like kiss my pussy.
He Chinese motherfuckers.
Wells Fargo Kissing your pussy since
1946 US Chinese mother fuckers aren't
kissing your pussies.
The stage coach slash gear plus the on
a bloody that open a checking account
tomorrow. Oh yeah. She's great.
And Mommy's coming here cause my Posey
uh,
let's see. Chinese motherfucker.
Racist fucking kid. Wow.
That's the part people pick up on, Huh?
Yeah. Out of that whole thing. Yup.
The Chinese part. Huh? This
is wrong. Recording vertical.
Good. That's really fantastic. Yeah.
This is a real work of art too. I
like this. Yeah. And there's more.
Let's see what else. Let's see.
Yeah. Everything else is building up.
Building up to that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. This shit so terrifying. Every
time I hear black girls yelling,
it brings me right back to
Portola junior high school.
Like I feel you got hired. Starts in
palpitate a little. You got jumped.
I got Jack a few times.
Yeah. Really? Oh yeah.
Structure.
They laugh their ass off because there's
screaming back and forth and she goes,
you know what? I'm not even going to
argue with Ya. So everybody laughs.
That's what I understand is
happening. Right. They're like, what?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
fucking so great. Now that the science of
this one, this happens to you in public,
is that you can't look like if you
notice nobody's doing the holy shit,
like you have to kind of subtly be like,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit. That's the hardest
part of witnessing something
like that. Remember our,
our buddy we're having dinner was saying
if you've watched the public thing and
they were all like,
he was at work.
All right.
I have so many things happen in a day now.
I wake up too early in the morning.
No know there's so much
to cover right now.
I know what you're talking about and he
was like, we were all like staring at,
you can't look when, when cool.
Should have. It's like that.
That's the Harvard of life.
I ain't even talking about it.
I don't know where you want to start
with because there's so much to go. Much.
I guess we could even go to last week.
I'm sorry to do this,
but I have to urinate because I drank
so much water. I'm sorry. I got to pee.
I'm going to take, if I do, I'll take
a picture and show you how clear it is.
I don't take it. No, I'm being
serious. I really do have to urinate.
We just took so long getting
ready. Just hit pause. I'll
be right back. No, come on.
I swear to God I have to
pee anyway. I just paid.
Would you like to see it? No, I don't.
Just look how light the color is. No,
I'm serious.
Just take note and how white the color,
but I'm just showing you how much
more I hydrated. Let me say it.
Okay, let's go. I'm ready. I'm ready.
So I
just got to drink more.
You're the worst
last week. One of the best Persian
phone calls ever. The best actually.
Or um, Sallie. May
mother fuckers
hope the boss.
Oh my God. Oh my God. For one month.
I mean it's some very, very up to
do.
Hmm. My friends Sleigh, um, sent me this.
He was listening to the Persian
is the time. You're right.
This is the best one.
She said.
Bolds do.
Said she is cussing a lot in Farsi
and it's explicit for an old lady.
So what she's saying is Salamay I
follow this, this block and Dennis,
he wrote question marks.
Yeah. Mother fucker. Thief.
That's what dose is,
I think.
And then close ghost case means slut,
but it's literal translation
is pussy stretcher.
So sees this motherfucker thief
pussy stretcher for one month,
since February has been stealing
motherfucker, I have a magazine,
I will give it to you.
Hold on to it.
The magazine has a list of attorneys
and real estate. So many attorneys,
you look fine,
an attorney interview one
for $150 and then get them.
But you need to look over the
attorney early, get so expensive. Uh,
those means thief. Ah, doors. Doors.
Yeah.
Salamay
uh, although I, as I recall,
she mentioned something
about Fry's electronics and
a video camera a while back.
Right. I may have heard her
say that Burke Chrysler's fat,
I'm not sure by the way.
She says in there,
in the beginning of that trickster Hogo
buzz or I don't know how to say it. Uh,
and God goes literal meaning his sister
fucker used as a very bad insult and
those a lot was just a thief.
So she goes off, you know,
wow, it's so amazing that seller
May, and the saga containment though,
we never call her back.
We try calling her back and we got her
voicemail and which was just meow, meow,
meow. And then when did this latest one
comes out? This one came a yesterday. Yes.
Yesterday.
So yesterday a new one came in.
Yeah.
From your mama ain't got time. You
call calling. I was at home depot.
We just had a phone call.
Yeah, a telephone call.
[inaudible] got home depot family talk
to the cause you telephone took Jason.
Why?
It's so funny how you,
um, other speakers, other
language speakers do that.
Like they'll throw in an occasional word
so that you feel like you kind of know
what's going on and occasional
what English one English
word that you understand
or like why would I talk
to you soon in English? Oh.
And I say that and you're a
little bit assimilated, right?
I'm just going to home depot.
You
both live here now. Kind of
thrown in some stuff, you know?
Can I talk to you soon? But yeah,
so the solid, now don't forget,
we called her back and it went to
voicemail. Yeah, yeah. Crazy. Yeah,
she's crazy.
But there's still,
there's still never ever interaction
back from south that we know of now. We've
tried calling her back to be like, hey,
we're getting these voicemails and I
just wanted to tell the reason I have
Solomon.
Well that's what you wanted to say.
What do you want to tell her? I
think Tommy's a guy, but I was okay,
fine. I'll have him. He's, he's in the
garage right now. What do you want?
What will you give me?
Like Richard Simmons, I want to do a
hostage situation. That's terrifying.
So I think tells me she will
not tolerate very upset.
She come over here. No
Way. Settlement, no way.
Soloman. Anyways, it
continues. The saga continues.
The Solow Mason never run
out of solid ways. No.
Very interesting.
In the non binary community,
apparently Dj dad mouth has been really
impacting legislation because nonbinary
is now a recognized gender
in Oregon and good work.
I also thank you,
first of all,
this is a personal victory.
I consider it for myself and for all the
other non-binary binary people in the
community,
people,
um,
that we've been wanting
to be recognized as such.
And if I'm going to,
if I could say so myself,
I'm happy to be recognized as probably
and binary. I'm proud to come
out as polyamorous than now.
I'm excited to share that
I'm bisexual and nonbinding.
I'm excited to share it.
Well,
I'm a little offended personally
because what about us? Astral genders,
you know what I mean? It's coming. Look,
it's going to be a long fight. Okay.
Just the fact that there are recognizing
some gender fluidity is what I'm happy
about.
That's the whole victory here.
But what about a,
I'm nonbinary.
My pronouns are not optional.
They them motherfucker. Yeah.
It's in my profile to my Twitter profile.
You have to be they them cause you
put it in parentheses, they them.
That's what you're supposed to
do. What? I'm binary. Well, okay,
you didn't know that I, I kind of
did. Yeah. I try not to know it.
Trying not to, trying not to
know, just too much information
in my head. Don't you think there's
only so much room in here? Yeah,
there's a, there's, there's
not a lot of room, so it's
true. It's tough to remember,
but I feel like I want to point
out that it's not a fucking option.
So if you ever want to talk
to me again or not an option,
they're not optional.
My very part of his video is that
he's wearing like a towel on his head,
like what your mom does when she gets
out of the shower, you know? Yeah.
My mother was always naked
as we discussed earlier,
and she'd come out of the shower and
she had these big Ol fucking milk tits,
like those deck, that cal thing. We,
Eric last week, you know, and has,
she had a Fryer,
crotch bright red cooch and she'd
always have her towel on her head.
And I just remember looking
at her body being like, God,
I hope I don't have a mom body like that.
And now I'm blessed with the same
exact figure. So that's neat.
I am too blessed to be serious.
I am too blessed to be stressed.
Where is the looking at Daddy?
I was looking at the very distracted.
I know.
Where's the appearance on as Dj Dad Mouth,
isn't it? Uh, your mom's
house you to page? Yeah. Yeah.
Go down to the unaired up playlists
section. Oh, there's a different section.
Yeah.
Like there should be a
okay
playlists. Yeah. Do you see
one that says I'm here? Yeah.
Yeah. That's where it
goes up there. Oh, okay.
So that's where big announcement is.
So I was looking at when I told
them I was non binary, you know,
I couldn't find a percent,
but it's still that that adds up the
male female binary and then I'm nonbinary
okay.
Well it was a big deal. It's
interesting. This is what,
this is why I don't like that.
She's laughing and you're,
you're bravely coming out.
It's like,
why don't you take his pro not wanting
to take their pronouns seriously?
What got this into Oregon's legislation.
Right.
You know, it's not a joke. It's not
funny. I don't like that. She's laughing.
Like I'm a busy guy, man. He said, hey,
announcement. I think announcement,
the big announcement, wanting to make
a, is it last year, you know, uh, uh,
I came out as poly and by, and
now I'm proud to say that, uh,
I'm non binary, you know, there's a big
deal. It's a big deal. So brave of Utah.
They kind of launched the whole thing. I'm
so proud of you. First of all, I guess.
Thank you for that. I want to say you're
welcome to everybody in Oregon. You, yeah.
So I don't,
so I don't understand.
Do you think it's like now you can take
that off like it's illegal to legal,
gender, male, female,
and now non-binary. Yeah.
Which, you know, all I can
see is that being helpful.
That's the cool thing is that
it's finally, it's like, ah,
thanks for simplifying all our lives,
streamlining everything.
Well also where your man or your woman,
how about neither? Neither. Got It.
Got It. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And also too,
the other genders now,
I mean there's so many other ones.
How come was kicking the door open?
We're excluding the astro genders,
the Demi genders and sec trolls
and the right just genders.
And horses, gender versus
gender is, but yeah, the dog
genders, the waffle gendered,
right. The, you know, earth
gendered. Yeah. Fairy gender,
whatever. It's a lot out there. I
mean, could there just be a box,
here's my preposition to you.
Okay, go ahead. Male, female.
And then just other like
all the other gender can,
I think would have actually what I mean,
probably the best way to write it in and
then that way everybody gets to have,
that's true.
I think that
just having the ability to go back and
forth from moment to moment is probably
the best solution so that you
could tell them right now in this,
but tomorrow I might not be right,
but then I might be again. Right.
And that would be like, okay, now,
now it's easy for us to
process all this information,
data statistics, you know,
we need to know this bureau.
All that would be like, you
know, right. Simplified fluid,
more fluid. Understood.
Understood. So anyways, yeah,
I was a proud to be an innovator or
pioneer in this, in this field. Yeah.
And I'm proud of myself. I'm proud
of myself. I'm proud of myself. Yeah.
I'm so happy. Thank you very much. Um,
am I supposed to bring up,
is, is, uh, is there a video?
Is it blurred out the stuff that I'm not
supposed to show? Yeah, it is. Okay, cool.
Yeah, it's all just audio, but the video
stuff I can pull down. Screams. Oh,
youtube. Same. Okay, cool.
Oh, there's a whole bunch of
stuff. What is this? A Hitler.
Let me see. Oh God, let's keep
that going. Oh, that's the
Dany X. Oh, Yay.
Some of the Dany Ex, uh, out there.
I know. You guys listen to it.
There's a, they're everywhere. You know,
I didn't know there's
a, um, offended. Yeah.
Look, they're holding it down. Um,
we should also point out that big
news in the business world today.
I don't know if you pay attention to that.
Well,
I pay attention to Twitter and then
we'd been tweeted at it a thousand times
today about it, so, oh, so you're
all still, I've been made aware.
Yeah. Okay. Cause normally I bring up our,
uh, new stuff and you're like,
ah, I've, uh, I don't know.
Yeah, that's how I am. That wasn't
in Cosmopolitan magazine. Right.
Linkedin is helpful.
Microsoft has purchased,
Linkedin is helpful. I know.
$26 billion.
That is unreal.
He 6.2 actually unreal. Did you know
linkedin? Was that helpful? I didn't know,
but apparently somebody knew the
truth. Linkedin is helpful. It's not a
right,
I didn't realize that.
I don't need the help
fuck off. You know, you
know, sizing the puppies,
they just use serious videos.
Serious videos like massaging or puppies,
fast whole animal husbandry and put a
laugh track in the background. Like, oh,
isn't that funny?
Our laugh track,
he's eating his shit.
Okay,
well that's good for linkedin.
I mean, good luck. Good.
Congratulations to
Lincoln Den. And also, um,
don't invite me to link and
then you lose a fucking loser
loser.
So
it would, it's fucking phenomenal that
that's what happened to Lincoln Den.
Yeah. Wow. Imagine. But again,
I think that that also is directly
related to your mom's house. I mean,
we've been pushing Lincoln
Den. Yeah. This is,
this is a big victory in, in
your mom's house history. Um,
and you know,
we just wanted to congratulate all the
link that helpful linkedin users and
especially Joey Diaz. He called
me, um, Saturday and said,
what's with the copy? Right infringement
cock sucker. I go, what? And he goes,
are you playing my video?
Yeah.
And I go, yeah, it was kind
of unavoidable. Can talk
about shitting in a tub.
He's like, that's, that's old me. I don't
do that though. I think it would. No,
I know. I remember your wife caught you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I don't do that no more.
I go, well, we couldn't avoid
playing it. Sorry. He was
like, no, it's all good. Yeah.
Yeah. The water would hit my ass. What?
I would just take a shit right there.
But on the log to the toilet,
oh my God.
Do you think that's true? Yes, it's
true. Yes. Yes. Yes. I think so too.
I do think it's true.
I think it's later then.
True.
Oh, dainty. Eric. We had a Damien. Yeah.
He said, oh, I didn't set up correctly.
So what we have here,
I hope she never takes her meds
better every time.
I just want to let you know there Italy
to my acts or really to a few of my Dany
Niac, they're on a shrimp
Scampi boat and uh, like they,
they're like getting turned
into Lasagna. So, oh,
I need your help getting a serious,
he died over there and
they really need your help
getting rescued. Hilly please,
please send a rescue boat over
there so that way they can be saved.
Hitler's on it. I was really
appreciate of cough. Damien.
I love Ya.
Oh, hello. I love you.
Let's recap. This was a, a shout out.
This one was an original oh gee to Hitler.
So Heather watches youtube.
We've established that and my friends
are on the shrimp scampi boats.
Actually Dany acts. So people
that, some two or fans,
they're turning in Lasagna.
And will you Hitler send a
rescue boat to save them?
I really need your help. I'm
serious. I, yes, of course.
I'm going to help your
daily Shrimp Scampi.
Last que te how was going to spend
this afternoon baking my favorite three
pastors and whatnot. That's ancillary.
I will rescuing y'all y'all last time.
Your friends
from the waters of the
shrimp Scampi. See, wow.
I wasn't drawing a bowl of
Muesli when I heard your message
of uh,
accidents and messages.
We have a Irish pub.
Oh my God. Thank God. I've been thinking
about those guys all week. What do,
I don't think a lot is happening in
that clip though. It, it doesn't.
So are the clips in here? Yeah, the
translation like matches up to the clubs.
Got You. Okay. Lincoln.
So let's see.
We have man,
last week we play the master
of accents is rarely stumped,
but good Lord.
Last week was really a challenge.
Luckily we had Kevin from Ireland.
Shout out to us.
Dear mom is shut out from land. Rick
Ireland. Huge fabric. Is it limerick?
Yeah, I dunno. I think, which one is it?
Limerick. L. I. M. E. R.
I. C. K. L. I. M. E. Yeah.
Yeah. Limerick. Okay.
Shut out from limerick. Oh. Hello.
Huge fan of the show. No, read
the whole thing in Irish dear bro.
Not I'll, I'll wait. I'm gonna
wait a second. Uh, he sure. Yeah.
Yeah.
A huge fan of the show in the standup
limerick is a county that borders Kerry
and Cork, which is where Gaddy and cure.
I wanted to help Tom with his impression.
He almost has a town that was doing an
awesome job I think with some translation
to what these gentlemen from carrier
are saying. He could nail it down.
I got most of it.
Um,
but this is because I have worked
in many bars here in Ireland.
It was still super hard to understand as
the guy that lives and works in bars in
Ireland from there. Is He, is he
a native? Yeah, he has trouble.
Oh boy. You're goes, all right,
let's see what we have here.
This was so fun. I actually,
it was amazing. Yeah. This
one was one of the hardest.
And what does [inaudible] mean to you?
Does it mean to play?
Because I ended up doing
with the last two years.
Okay.
He says, what does the a
relocation relocate of the pub mean
to you? And he says, God,
it means a pint because
I haven't had a drink.
Would lash two years,
which means,
cause I have not had a drink for the
last two years. Oh, bullshit. Yeah. Yeah.
Well that's his job. Yeah. Oh,
okay. Yeah. Sorry, I didn't,
I can't tell humor and thick.
Yeah, that means a player because I
ended up doing with the last two years.
How about a drink the last two years ago?
Are they, they're almost
depressing, right?
Almost like the Blues Traveler Guy.
Dude.
He is the best. Isn't that Joe? That's
the guy from the blues traveler.
Joe Is something else, man. Most chops.
They are really depressing, right?
Jeans. Oh my God. Yeah, of course.
This is a horrible life.
All you care about it. Yeah.
All right, cool. Well what,
wait, what about the blues
traveler guy is coming up. Oh,
okay.
What does it
mean to,
we keep up to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that we have down to dealing with him.
Tangelos done.
[inaudible]
this well Eileen.
Okay. If I was raped though,
I give it a way we, all right.
We actually got a translation.
Oh wait, see this? Alright.
So interviewer asked again, what is the
opening in the pub mean to you? He goes,
well, and this is where it kind
of makes sense for a second.
Well it means a lot cause you keep up the
tradition of singing and the music and
everything like that.
So let's get to that real quick about
the tradition of fixing your teeth.
That's it. Not a tradition I adhere
to. So maybe we could start with that.
Cool. Me Too. But it means
we keep up to solution.
We really kill him.
Anything.
Well it means a lot because
so far I got it. I think. Yeah,
I think it just translate it
and I think we've got that.
We got singing and the music and
everything like that. And then he said,
then he put it in parentheses.
This was very hard to understand
something like there's a great dancer.
It was a great dance or darts,
beautiful old dance here,
Jig sets.
Um,
and then he goes Jig sets and tangos
then something laughs and foxtrots uh,
with things. Right. We're, we're
back to square one again. Okay.
Let's see if that hearing
that makes sense. Let's see
if that makes sense. Okay,
cool.
Christ Tangelos
uh,
what was,
he was ready to give me a little
bag of tea and this letter, Wiley.
Holy Shit. I think he basically got
it. I think he basically got it. Yeah.
I Dunno how you fucking understood that.
But now it makes more sense.
And now for the master of accidents will
appear and give this a shot and listen
one last time,
please
wait, wait, wait. You keep up to sedation
seniors? We really kill him when Linda,
yeah,
that we have down to dealing with.
No,
we have dancing and
I'm almost there.
I can't even watch it.
You need to be missing teeth to make
the sound good. Now you have any days
building
Derek?
Yeah.
Dig Ditches. Karen goes, okay.
Okay.
Black stuff.
Who is he in [inaudible]
every year square. Right. Again,
things are right.
We're back to square one again.
I wasn't even fucking says wasn't. I think
I want to be raped and square way, way,
way
back to God. Oof.
That is terrible.
Uh,
all right.
All right.
Really,
it's really that that footage that
doesn't look like a first world country.
That could have been Kyrgyzstan.
Yeah. I've been to curious, Dan,
that looks like shit.
Although sheep and I guess we're not doing
a live podcast and carry kids running
around in eastern bloc and tracks
when we add video.
Yes. Yeah. He translated it.
You Ready? The guy asks him,
God dammit, had you missed the pub when
it burnt down, you missed it badly.
I'd say,
and the guy says,
we have where we're after
building up an awful lot of money.
We'll have to spend it now. That's the
biggest job. Now we can, we can spend it.
That's really what it says.
Yeah.
I never would have guessed that in a
million course who would have guessed it,
but hey,
burnt on you,
Mr [inaudible] idea.
Gary, have you beat me
up? You had your baby
just to be a week
zombies
and we can spin it.
Wow. I think you should be him for
Halloween. That would be an easy costume,
Joe Kelly.
Yeah,
and you just take a hammer
and not 17 of my teeth out.
She's but a scarecrow hat on
some fake mutton chops, man.
Oh,
it's depressing.
Tim. What, what's it like to have the pub
when we go on little one,
when we were able to visit and
I'm coming here, we'll have the news.
Depression. You'll have the crack.
The crack.
Sorry.
So that is, I don't know that we want
to know what they're saying this.
I'll just read it and then back in.
All right.
What's it like to have the pub open? It
sure is. It's great for meeting people.
We'd like, we'd meet, we'd be knowing
when we're out of it and you call it,
you have locals all the time coming,
you know the news of the place.
You have the crack and you have
the, he really did say it. Yeah.
You have to carry fellows
here and a cork man.
They're talking about cork and
Cary county. Gotcha. Um, yeah,
so everyone's thrilled
that the fucking bars open.
Yeah. Apparently the big news and
entire documentary bar. Huh. And
uh, but thank you so much Kevin
from Ireland for that translation.
It's amazing.
I always,
I've said this to Scottish people
and some Irish people and like,
do you realize that your speaking the
language the way it's supposed to be
spoken?
Like what I'm saying is actually
the pig fucking version of it.
Where the trailer trash.
Yeah.
English language and that I can't
understand that God cause they don't have
trouble understanding us. No, we
are the ones who were like wow,
they're speaking it more correctly.
Basically Queens, the Queens, English.
Unbelievable. I can't understand
English speaking people. Um,
so, oh, so this is the one to show
you, uh, are dear, dear friend.
Um,
Kim in,
she's back.
She is so bad.
Her how could you not miss her
to wait a long PainEase Oh yes.
Am I had to say back then
as hell.
I believe you.
What do you do?
Call the rectum to gentlemen,
Gentlemen. She um, oh boy. She really,
really goes to work on this one is,
Oh man,
let me just set this up.
Oh,
you're ready for the scene?
This guy is a savage boy,
basically should be playing
tight end in the NFL. And he, uh,
he really,
I didn't think you could say it's fair
to say it gets quite aggressive, right?
I mean. Yup. And, um, she's so old.
I'll forget that smell.
We do the scene.
We always fuck heart our way.
I like to share with you
ancient sex
judge Sachs. Ancient. Oh, I
think she meant to say secrets.
And instead she said
ancient, like, I want you to,
I'm going to show you my
ancient posey here in a second.
Rouse been study a lot
about this ancient secrets.
There you go.
Because I know that all of us,
our energies feel,
and what you need to do is
be mindful about your spine,
especially in the vagina,
your vagina.
That's a port of entry.
So this is what you need to do.
You need to stop judgment
from right or wrong,
and you need to listen
to me to listen to me
super hard.
They don't want you to eat checkers.
You to was that
mean? Yes. Do you think
he knows that Word Babe?
Ejaculate work. I want you to,
when you're a super hard no,
Jen command. Oh, did do it to her.
Um, well distracted by a rag to, oh wait,
can I ask her name?
You don't need to listen to me. You need
to where you agree. They said to me,
agrees. Okay. Okay. When you
really, really super hard,
you made a baby super high.
Eight until one.
You don't want you to you to hold a home.
There you go. A decade lay, she gets,
I like when she pluralizes
the wrong thing.
D spinals and energy.
Ancient Age and sex.
Okay.
Yeah. A sexy Shane. Shane Sanchez.
Yeah. It should be. I'm a
little different. I should
be ancient sex secrets,
I think. Yeah. Um,
but let's get,
is there a audio then over this?
It's just the isolations throughout
that conversation. Oh, really? Not the,
the, the picture there. It
should be a picture in that
folder. Oh, the Jujitsu? Yeah.
Okay. Look, this is from the scene. Oh No,
no. She's a grandma. I know,
but do you see what he's doing?
No. Nelson. So, oh, Jesus
Christ. Here's this.
But then he went under her legs and
then on the back of her head, oh,
I don't like that. Oh, you
shouldn't, it's not nice.
Her bones are brittle. She's
all, she's like, oh, whoa.
Not hit my ass house. It's, it's
way too aggressive. Like it. Yeah,
it's too, it's too much. So
grandma, yeah. I mean, he has,
he has a grandma and basically choke.
Yeah.
Like I demand more for Kim Man.
Oh,
she needs to raise her standards a
little bit. Yeah. Um, it's pretty,
pretty incredible. A lot
of people, by the way,
are moved motivated by the
virtus fat phenomenon that's taken over.
Yeah.
And he has,
uh, started to push back a
little bit. Yeah. He made some
videos and see if we have them
here. Oh yeah. Here this is him.
He posted this.
Okay.
It's supposed to be
okay.
That's good. Yeah. It was
pretty funny. That's, um,
that's me with faceswap. Yeah. Um,
of course the irony is that he actually
ate the ice cream, of course, to,
to make fun of me. Right.
Um, let's see if I can,
he made a great one that really made
me laugh and his hotel room, um,
where he faced swapped me on to him and,
uh, and made an apology. I think you can,
I'll see if I can pull up.
He was doing it apparently all
weekend on his snapchat. He was just,
he made a snapchat just for this.
Yeah. Just to do this. Yeah.
Because it's a very new
account. Yeah. He's done. He's
done really well by the way.
People are,
I've told us that they're going back to
the tattoo parlor to have roommate oh
eight.
Oh No. From, from that look.
Better late than never guys.
Um, there's a, there's a
bunch of birdies fat stuff though.
It's getting out of control. Yeah.
Um, why can't I find, here we go. Here's,
here's what Burt did right here.
See if this plays
okay guys,
it's a big Tom Square up.
Just want to apologize for starting
this whole big fat campaign on bird.
It's a really good,
yeah, it's funny. Yeah.
It's a not fair. I'm just so
much better than I know that.
No, I'm well aware of
it. So, uh, I'm sorry.
The best part about this is that
people were there. Like, Tom,
you really do look really fat here in
this photo right now that you're on birds
phase. You look really,
really fast. Oh man,
there was so many good ones. I think
it's motivating Bert to slim down a bit.
It's motivated everybody. I know that
it's motivated Bert to stop night eating.
I have a source, I won't, I won't
reveal my source. Yeah. In Chicago,
he's at the Improv and I got a text
message, hey Burt's here. Yeah.
And I go tell him he's fat.
Yeah. And my source when,
it's funny you mentioned that because he
wanted to eat late at night and he said,
I can't because too many
people are calling me fat.
So we're actually making a
dent in Burt's dieting plan.
The funny thing is his efforts
to push backers so much weaker.
Right. I got two tweets that
are clearly from people.
They were at the show that
he was doing like, um,
and like I'd look at the,
the where they are and they're in Chicago,
which is where he is. And they're like,
Tom, you're you're fucking fat or yeah,
I just saw bird. He's clearly
been working out. I'm like,
did he dictate this to you?
Yeah.
Um,
and then
I, we just see a hundred yeah.
To Burton or clearly winning.
It's a landslide victory. The bird is
clearly better than you know. I know.
Clearly fatter. There's,
there's no comparison. We
even have a,
a song somebody made a fucking song.
Is that in the folder?
No.
Uh, they actually might be. I think
it might be standalone. Standalone.
A MC. Yup. Here it is. Okay,
shout out to and Cora and Christina.
I know.
Sorry.
Yo,
where is fat blurt that
strawberries like a fucking fool.
He's wearing a stuffed
shirt back in certain labs.
Give them something to not tie in.
Three polo shirts together with butter.
Butterfat his legs don't fit in these
pants. You rock your shirt under that.
Don't get no one. Mind it, but dude
don't have bro. Shit. Looking, no beast.
Hold Geese. Couple of more years common
to hear. Please mute. Take a cheeseburger.
Flesh eating disease. Real. Didn't
even talk about birds baldness. No.
Yeah. Well it's a first. It's better.
It's a five minute
distraction trying to dis but he ain't
ready for combat to Martin Martin Tremble
waste massive unraveled baking
skills like dream on out
crazy. Lokes uh, featuring Mc
and I'm saying it's really, yeah.
Patriot
burn fat.
TV's sacral has her fingers
were all some of us. This
would I seek to be sad.
You should read it to you know,
five
sites son being fat. Like
you ain't bright sun. No,
no
but like two he hears it.
You see it starting Ronnie go for,
you know, saying straight up. Don't
quit eating all that greasy food.
I'm keeping it so true.
So crazy to do some Skype punch is crazy
low. So you've got to help or hurt.
How about crazy lugs? So sending us that
fucking fire track man. Thanks. Awesome.
Thanks. Lokes. Thank you. Yeah.
We haven't even addressed births baldness
because it's fat and this kind of
overshadows yeah, but it is
true man. That is very true.
Wow. Yeah. Um, um, hold on. Oh,
can we bring up what, what the panic
at the disco sending? Yeah. Yeah.
Brandon. Uri, yes. Yes. Uh,
lead singer of panic at the disco.
Is that how you say it? Well,
who's to say it?
Because he sent a message out that he's
officially changing the name to a mommy.
Right, right. And then I was like,
Hey, is that true when you said it's a,
the is ongoing,
I wonder how the record label feels about
that change. Um, well he said, you know,
I don't care.
My priorities are what they are.
He's gonna throw his career in
the toilet for your mom's house.
He said that he's actually putting it
on a pedestal by doing that. So, right.
I know that it's going
to take a while to come,
but he said the website's going to be
changing and all the material is going to
be changing very soon. Yeah. Wow. Uh, wow.
I did a real mommy. Yeah. And He, uh,
he messaged us this video that he,
you said,
I put this up and I didn't realize
that I was a profit. Um, unbelievable.
It's really unreal that this is a
oh no.
Ah,
right.
So now there's just gaping hole.
It is.
Okay.
I love his commitment.
Yes.
Hello?
Eh,
you guys got some funny kind of
a reason. There are a big deal,
Huh? Yeah. Cheese, cheese. But isn't that
crazy that he wrote that song? I mean,
before even your mom's house.
Yes. Incredible. Amazing. Yeah.
That guy's really got an amazing voice.
Talk about, yeah. Talent. Holy Shit.
Yeah. Jesus Christ. So
funny. Yeah. She retaliated.
I just thought of it because of his
voice also has a Bo Burnham. Oh,
I haven't watched his special,
if you watched it. I haven't
seen it. Is it really?
That's your age demographic. He's
fucking that kids. So talented. Yeah,
I'm watching it. I will. Yeah. It's
called like make happy. Yes. The new one.
I've got a few.
I think that's why I won't click on it
because I'm such a miserable fuck that
I'm like, I don't want to
be happy. Let's get this.
Let's watch Anthony Bourdain again. I
think your assessment is correct. No,
let's get snarky. But he's one of
those guys that you, if you get,
when you watch it, you'll just
be like in all of that's amazing.
Talented that guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right.
He's just like that guy when the natural
man, I mean, how old is Brendan Urie?
That guy looks like he's 12 years
old and he's like a major deal. 20th.
That's crazy. But how do you, what do
you start when you're like magic box?
They may start at such a young age.
God,
he is 29. Oh my God. So good.
And uh, let's see. So amaze
25. Oh my God. Get your life
has at least two specials,
right?
He did. Um, yeah,
he did a comedy central thing. One called
Bo Burnham, one called words words,
words one called what we called make happy
one, two, three, four, five specialties.
And he wrote that television show.
Zak Stone is going to be famous.
That was really, really celebrated even
though it didn't last that long. Wow.
Yeah. Thursday. He's just one
of those like super, you know,
so crazy.
Yeah.
Now I don't know if you've been keeping
up with Garth Brooks lately, uh,
speaking of musicians, but if you want
to take a gander at his Facebook page,
there's some choice videos.
I, I often look up, uh,
Garth's social media. Yeah. Yeah.
He doesn't really,
I don't feel like he really grasps how
to handle social media and Google stuff.
Slick stuff. Neat stuff. Yeah.
Okay. He's such a dad does,
it doesn't sound right,
but
just pull up his Facebook page
if you, if you would. And okay.
I gotta you gotta look at the his beard
situation that he's got going. Okay.
It's not good. Really. It's not good.
And I know you as a beard
Aficionado, uh, there's,
there's an art to how you style the beard
to keep your face from looking weird,
right? Yeah. So look at his videos.
Okay. That he's posted. Slick
stuff. Neat stuff. Okay.
Oh my God. It's so embarrassing.
Wasn't it? Go down.
You got to do it from the corner.
Oh Dad.
But it won't,
Oh, dad moved the moved over. There
it is. That's the video. Yeah.
Andover. Live it to the rent a little
bit. There you go. Now try it. Okay. Um,
dad,
that's the video.
Just like this is a video up for
there and under the about. Oh,
just click on that. Oh God.
I know. Look at his beard.
You're going love it.
So creepy. Right? Opening night
live. Here we are in Saskatoon.
Actually.
That's terrible. That's terrible.
Right? Well it's a, it's,
he has a fully clean face.
Yeah.
And he has what would be a goatee
except there's no side connector and no
mustache. And it's not a, it's
not a little soul patch. No.
The the Chin only and it's fun.
It's, it's like five day stubble.
It's horrific. Yeah. A just a chin patch.
It looks like an old man
when you shut off for like,
everybody's really excited about getting
back. And I can tell you right now,
we have a lot of cute
stuff on this one here.
Actually for the first
time to get Aaron in here.
He's the guy that opened the whole show.
Karen is about to go on.
So we gotta make this quick because
they're doing the turnaround right now and
that keep people kind of in the arena.
He's gotta be insufferable.
Right direction 40 quick. She just
will be kind of short tonight. Okay.
I want to make sure to say hey to
everybody back in music fest in Nashville.
Huh? It's a 10 minute video. It's so low.
What do you guys look?
Everything's going well.
There are in the greatest city on planet
man that tunes the greatest city on the
planet. Should we love
you guys? This you guys.
But I cannot tell you how
happy is in Saskatoon. Yeah.
Said I thought he was saying you in the
greatest on the planet to the people
back wherever. Oh, okay.
Certainly not Saskatoon.
Yup. Loud tonight. So real
excited. Okay, first thing,
let's just kick the here I got here.
No,
we're somewhere fair
cowboy.
This one you guys,
he's so tiny.
No
loud enough for you.
You got to help me.
But I hear Bon Jovi.
Oh Man. So this is like some
just natural. It's boring, right?
Let's go on for 10 minutes. I'm saying,
I just don't think he gets how it works.
Shorter is better.
It's going to be the funnest train wreck.
Dude says hi Garth.
Where's Tricia? Tricia is in the
Glam squad right now. She's a,
she's a getting made up and get
ready for her part of the shelf.
One thing I will say, Trish was
his girl. She's a, that's his,
is she a musician? But before
he met him, she's the real deal.
A real deal.
But um,
I do like that he's talking about her
getting glammed up and then he always
looks like he's just like
going to seven 11, you know,
like he always has just like a hat
sweatshirt. Really like dads it down.
By the way, speaking of Dads, did you,
did you pick up on these uh,
uh, Steph curry sneakers?
The curry to Lowe's home.
Sorry. All right. So,
I know you're not really into
sneaker culture, but you know,
ever since Jordan exploded and for
people that don't know and you know,
he's still the most dominant shoe brand,
like as far as every basketball player,
the big thing is to not just get signed
by Nike or Adidas, but then your shoe,
your shoe. Yeah. So it's like these
are the Colbys, these are the Lebrons,
you know, so and then every year it
will be like, here's a new release.
It's the new Lebron, right? So
it's, and then shoe collectors,
it's like a whole thing.
Like, you know, they get into,
I got the new lebrons or I got the
new kobies. Steph curry is the,
like the hottest thing in basketball
right now. It's, you know,
people are arguing whether he's the guy
that's overtaking that top spot from
Lebron, you can make a big
case that, you know, I mean,
he's the best shooter we've
ever seen in NBA history.
He plays for Golden State
and they're playing against,
Lebron is California,
Oakland.
So they're playing against Lebron right
now in the finals. But to simplify, look,
the main thing is that he's,
he's a huge, huge star. Um,
arguably the biggest star currently.
And so his new sneaker came out
and it's current. It's the curry.
I think the curry too low.
Let me see.
Curry two shoes. Here we go. Um,
and they have been just been
getting assassinated because they,
everyone's saying they
look like dad shoes.
Oh, that's funny. But I mean
they got matched one is it,
I'm trying to find the
good picture of them,
but they got absolutely
massacre. I know. Um,
I think when this loads correctly,
you'll see,
uh,
cause he's been defending them.
But people are saying like the curry two
loads do not look like stability and a
700 credit score in the shoe. Like
this year. I get it. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. It's just like they just got
massacred with dad jokes, you know,
like just horrific dad jokes.
And as you can see with our
awesome internet situation,
so we have like a thousand
different internet connections,
two lines.
It's in here.
The routers in here in a certain
hard line and your computer into it.
How that's a good idea. Okay. Just, uh,
I now see in red,
I'm ready to fucking throw
this thing through a window,
but I'm gonna keep going.
All right, now we're back. So now you
can see them. Those are horrible, right?
Those are such dad sneaks.
Oh my God.
You look like stability and
a to have a hundred credit.
There's such Obama's right.
Cops are on their way. Three
horror. Let me speak to your manager.
Fives. Hilarious. Yes. Officer right here.
I saw everything.
Seven amazing.
Uh,
Beyonce formation is disrespectful to
police officers and 11, so hilarious.
Yeah. And so, and then he's of
course make America great. Yeah.
Huh. Uh, I
was told by apple care.
Great.
And then he of course is the very thing,
he's defending his shoes,
obviously multimillion dollar contract,
but they look straight up like dad shoes
right now. Those are terrible. These are,
I've resigned, terrible,
terrible. Don't touch my penis.
And then he can say that all he
wants, you know, and people say, uh,
under fired their head of design.
Yeah.
It's task through this backlash and they
rehired. They're old head of design.
Who had gone to Nike and came back. Oh
Wow. Yeah. It was because of this. Yeah.
I mean not, and that's not
cool at all. And I'm not,
I don't know shit about cool snakes,
but those aren't terrible. Yeah. Um,
I'll tell you who does wear it.
Like Garth is like, I'm mad,
I'm Jim knew south courage to
Lowe's isn't fucking dope man.
Really. Somebody who hasn't seen this
show. It breaks my heart to say this.
And I also say what's the most pride?
Because she knows the
highlight of the show.
I cry every time and I know I
shouldn't be used to it by now,
but just love that woman lover challenge,
pleased and very thankful.
We're very lucky to be jury.
Throw up all their obs is
the best part of the show.
Can you believe that bullshit?
No. I mean, look, you and I,
we support each other in
comedy, but we never, I,
I really feel like it's so weird.
G
double handling.
Don't you think it's so I'm forced to do
that shit with your spouse all the time.
Like Eric, I mean, we
are so in love Maine.
Tricia a picture right there.
She's the best.
She steals the show
though. Yeah, sure. Yeah.
Right. Oh, there they are buying
tickets to see Trish. Yeah.
Or Garcelle girl. They would,
so they would buy tickets
to see her if she's okay.
I just don't know that world.
But he's definitely a bigger
name. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's so funny. Yeah. He
now I love her so much.
We got to declare our love more
publicly, Tom. That means it's real.
Let me see if this came through.
I um, did that night go through.
God dammit. What are you
going to do? Who's Dick?
You got to suck to make
this shit work around here.
You know what's wrong then? I'm looking
for this, a email to come through.
It always gets kicked out of my me thing,
you know? Yeah. Go ahead and take a look.
Go to the next thing.
Um, okay. Well it kind
of involves you go ahead.
So we were playing with baby jeans this
weekend and you were doing airplane with
him and there's so many times I've wanted
to show you videos online of babies.
When you hold them over your head,
you've got to be careful because they
will vomit and it'll hit your face.
And I've always been like shy,
show them those videos na and
it happened to you.
Vomited into my mouth, into
my mouth so warm so much.
It was horrifying for me cause
you know I'm a vomit. Oh yeah.
I think the whole, the whole world
knows me. And that was like, we all,
everybody froze except
for the baby obviously.
And I ran and I got a burp cloth
and wiped you off and you were like,
I tasted in my mouth, toys, his word.
Come on.
Yeah, it was like that.
It was like that. And um,
it was pretty incredible men.
Um, a couple of things stood out.
First of all, I didn't even flinch.
Right. I didn't even flinch. He just went,
we were like this and he
went black and you're like,
I just sat him on my chest.
Yeah. Frozen. I was like,
I just stayed looking
at him and I was like,
help me out here and you
got a blanket or a wipe.
Oh my God, it's all in your beard tail.
Oh, it was so much. I had to shower.
I could taste it.
I could smell it
later because the smell is
really, you're like, Huh.
It's crazy how that's the
thing about having a kid.
It doesn't even really bother you.
Yeah, it's not, it wasn't that gross.
I don't know if I would've
reacted as well as you did,
cause I don't mind cleaning up his shit.
He could shit on me and I'd be like,
yeah, I can't wait for him
to Puke in your face. Wow.
That's literally my biggest dream
right now is for him to Puke.
I'm terrified of it. Of course
he's going to, I don't want it.
Anyway. I thought that was
really funny. Absolutely.
My 40th birthday is on Saturday.
Holy Shit. Are you going to,
what are you going to do for me?
Please send Christina happy
63rd birthday messages.
It's really amazing, Huh? I know.
I feel like we're so much more
juvenile than our parents were. Right.
I like horse thinking.
I can actually remember my dad's 40th
birthday a little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
Because they had a surprise party for him.
So it's like slapping my mind a little
bit, but he's such like a, I dunno,
just so much more of a
grownup. I felt like, you know?
Yeah. Cause they had more
responsibility earlier.
We didn't get this much responsibility.
I'd have a kid until I was like 39
so we didn't really, um, you know,
people are always like, I feel like I'm 20
still. Like I don't, I feel like I'm 60.
I do feel, I don't think I've ever
felt young. I like getting older.
That's the other thing. People are always
fighting it and I'm like, it's great.
It's great. I do, I
like it. I like it too.
I don't like so much happening
around and getting closer to death,
but every other other part of it's
fine with me. Yeah, I agree. I don't,
not too traumatized by it. I mean,
look, I live in La. When the time comes,
I get the surgery on my face.
Fix whatever's
fallen. Yeah. Are you going to do that?
Pull it up, pull it back? Yeah. Oh yeah.
That's what, when it's when it's, I need,
I think 10 more years on a few things
and not get these eye bags done and I get
my tits hoisted back up and to some
reasonable place. Yeah. Uh, maybe I'll,
I'll do that,
but I'm,
I don't want to get like big Kim
Mans those look too hard on her body.
Is there a way just to get normal looking
tits? Like to get them high. Higher,
but like not hard and weird. I can
they make them look like for her tits.
I think command got them in Bangkok,
so that's why you look like that.
But they're full of heroin these days.
You can go to,
you can go to Beverly Hills, man. Yeah,
the SUPERNAP Supernet
it'd be look bigger shows.
You can tell him I'm tired
of these big tits fart and
I want you to de gas them. And they'll
be like, hey, no problem. Thank you.
There's so hanging. Hey, can we talk about
my new favorite show on Netflix? Yeah.
Um, let me get this plug in
real quick. Oh yeah. I, uh,
I did charge it to the game
again. Uh, this time, ah,
a j Hawk was,
I'm in studio and it's really interesting.
We talk about all kinds of stuff,
um,
from every aspect of his career too.
You know,
just regular, it's like such a good
podcast. We talked just comedy, fun stuff.
He's a great talker. Yeah. And I think
smart guy, I think I had this clip set up.
He's a guy who,
who actually won a national championship
in college and a super bowl as a pro
and there's not that amazing.
I mean, it's been done,
but not that many people win championships
at the two highest levels in American
football. It's pretty, we had him
over at the Mommy Dome, if, I mean,
can I say that? Am I allowed? Yeah.
I don't think he'll mind. I made,
I made a shake and bake and
macaroni and cheese. Yeah.
And we had dinner with him and he's
so down to earth for someone that's
accomplished so much. You wouldn't know.
He's so humble. Pie would think he is.
I asked him like,
what's the normal thing he ever purchase
with all his NFL money? He's like, Oh,
I love the I and a nice house. One time.
He was like, is that it? Yeah. Yeah.
I so sweet. Yeah. Um, let's see.
Uh, can I play this file here?
I Dunno if I can, I'm trying to
play you this really cool thing.
Cool stuff is real except for neat stuff.
So yeah.
I mean you've one of the few guys,
you won a Superbowl in
a national championship.
Is there anything that is like similar,
consistent on championship
teams like that?
Like an outlook from
the players or the team?
Yeah, I mean the culture in the
locker rooms, crazy clothes.
I think everyone really gets along,
hangs out and just really
wants to be around each other.
And then we had that a common thing,
that common core,
that thread that ran through. It was
like everyone was always wondering like,
why is burned Chrysler
so fat?
It's pretty great. Right? I mean even an
NFL locker rooms are talking about, wow,
wow. Charge it to the game. That's great.
Please subscribe. Listen, it's
on iTunes. It's on stitcher.
Even in the NFL, even NFL
man. Uh, pretty great.
Pretty Great. Listen, I
got, can we play that clip?
Vegas seven Oh two. Sure.
I've been, I think about it.
She sent it to us on Twitter
and it's such a cute little,
this is supposed to be,
it could be our son in a few years.
Is that what that's been
Alice set up, Chris. So
who's this kid?
Just the,
today I'm going to be
listening to Melody Martinez.
Second single off her new home,
crowded me coming out August
14th and it's called soap. Um,
apparently here's the confirmed
and recorded track list,
but might not be the actual track list.
It's just the ones that
she's confirmed in recording.
So he's definitely like a southern
boy. Yeah, you can definitely hear it.
He might be a Carolina kid.
He's Melanie Martinez,
some Teeny dos
alphabet boy dos halfhearted.
Still haven't heard. Pity party
trying to, we'll still haven't
heard soap about to here. Um,
haunted.
Still haven't heard.
See because I haven't heard sippy
cup to her songs for babies.
Haven't heard bump on Monday. I haven't
heard a teddy bear or haven't heard.
I'll toss that had our y'all a
thousand words haven't heard home too,
so.
Gotcha.
I'm going to look up who the hell Melanie
Martinez is as he's listening to this
song that we don't want to get
flagged on youtubes with. Um,
but Melanie, Tina's, yeah,
the titles. Those songs sounded really
babyish. Like Citi Taiwan cookies.
Yeah. Child. Yeah.
American singer songwriter. Oh, she
was on the voice. The poor girl.
Other girl got killed this weekend.
A ball. Um, please watch him dance.
So please tell him. Look
at him. Yeah. I honestly,
he did a version of this.
Of course you did.
We all did this shit when you were 13.
Thank God there was no,
I'm saying I'm still doing something like
this. When you listen to your Rihanna.
Yes. See, listen to where
I, where I basically do.
Yes. This is how you dance. Absolutely.
Show me was kids feeling it, man. Show me.
I get up. Look how he, he
really goes, you something.
Okay.
I just feel alive in life.
Very nice.
Some new mommy at the disco.
There he goes,
damn.
Ooh.
Oh
so cute.
You loved it. Last verdict. My conclusion,
like you just tasted
some food right there.
Could you imagine if
there was at this age,
how much dumb shit you and out of so
many videos that would be mortified by?
I would have been like super goth,
put up golf videos,
so embarrassed. Just thinking about what
I would do. I would have had a lot. Yeah.
Well, what'd you talk about at that
age? I would have thought that,
I don't know.
Every time I talked shit to somebody,
I would think it's funny and you know,
I probably would have walked.
I remember walking around a party,
went through the camera,
just clowning people in it. I probably
would uploaded that and oh my God, it was,
I'm sure just terrible.
You know, it makes me,
it makes me cringe inside
me to think about it. Yeah.
Are you thinking about yourself doing
it? Yeah. Cause we got a cam quarter,
you know,
in 1988 or something like that where I
was 12 or 11 I just remember like hours
in front of that thing doing commercials
for fake products and singing like I
was, you know the singer,
whatever. Oh that's embarrassing.
By the way,
can we get a mom and wondering what
you think if I should give this a shot,
I don't know. Would you rather to, okay.
Hi,
I'm Elena Pagosa and while I'm a wrestler,
so I usually try to do one
deep tissue massage a month.
I heard about Dr and she has this
thing called the bite massage.
Yeah.
Hi, nice to meet you. I'm Alina.
So what is the bite massage consist of?
Cause I usually extraditing
well but is it usually extra?
Do you call it? Do you add an
additional cost if they want that? No,
no.
I started out the massage with that before
we put all the messy creams and oils.
Do you wipe them down?
You don't wipe your clients down,
don't you get grossed out?
No, you are grossed out.
You should not be massage therapists. I've
seen it all and smells it all. Oh God,
I've seen it all. Smelled the nervous
about the bite massage because I don't,
it's a different technique, so no,
I'm open to it and get over
it. Yeah, it feels good.
Don't be afraid. I started doing this
when I was five years old and my mom,
because she wanted me to massage her,
but my hands weren't strong enough so
she just kept saying, bite me, bite me.
So I've been doing this my whole life.
It sounds strange and unconventional,
but it's to die for. Okay. Okay.
Hopefully all day it won't hurt no
more. Okay, here we go. Why? Why?
I told ya? I don't know. I don't
know. It's all inviting your back.
There's literally no other way to
explain it, but it feels really good.
Sometimes they do. People
buttocks, right? Knowing on it.
She's subsiding pervert. It looks like
a little rat. This is her thing. Wait,
but wait til you hear why. The reason
why my clients are mostly celebrities,
it's a simple reason. I wanted to get in
free to see concerts when I was little.
I wanted to meet the people on stage who
write the lyrics that I hold so close
to my heart and therefore I thought,
hm, I'm very good at massages.
So how about if I try to barter?
Basically?
Yeah.
It feels good.
Right?
It's almost like getting beat out of
you when you come to me. You know,
she gave her client list at one
point and it was David Bowie.
Uh,
wow.
I had on the list on the cheat
sheet. It's on there. Yeah. Wow.
And she bit David Bowie?
Yes.
[inaudible] oasis. They got their
first massage ever from no love. No,
they'd never had massage was kind of
like those too. And she bit there.
They're buttholes and yeah.
About your ball bag.
I think she does do that exact same thing.
Well, if it's like staying and stuff,
she was a groupie. Yeah. Yeah. Well
that's what it sounds like. She's saying.
That's how I got started in this, you
know? Yeah. Just by index and stuff. Yeah.
How'd you like the, the bite massage
you think? No, I don't want that.
I want that either. I don't
need her to do that. No.
Stick to the elbows and
fingers. Yeah, I agree.
So crowding. It sounds a little. Yeah.
I mean, I do like this. She does not,
she's not bothered by smells.
Wow. It's only smells very much.
Only smell. What do you think your
asshole smells like when you go in? Uh,
I try to be nice about it and
wash it, you know? Yeah. Yeah.
He had a lot of brown this morning.
Yes.
I think something happened yesterday.
We had those Sandy's and I
think it messed me up too,
because I took two dabs today. Yeah.
And the second one wasn't healthy.
It wasn't good. Well, um,
it was painful and hot.
It was, um, were ready to
get into this. You got your,
your, yeah. Okay. I
have to pee again.
Hydrated so much.
The top layer.
Did you
chunk
the urine? Homeless? Am I
have sex with your sister?
They gave the face.
Grandmother walks in on you masturbating.
Never have another orgasm.
It's time to play.
Would you rather
this
you rather is brought to
you by patriarchy? Patron,
Nate Brown.
Nate builds ships. Oh, in,
uh, closer to Iceland. And then for fun,
he tries to see how far they'll
go without thinking. And,
and a lot of times he doesn't get far,
he says,
but he just keeps building them and
he's lost. Um, one leg in one finger.
Oh, due to frostbite. Oh my gosh.
He's a hardcore patriot and patron patron.
And he's a the official sponsor of
this. Would you rather, so don't forget,
go to patrion.com/mom be a patriot and
patron and get bonus episodes and extra
content. All right. Jeans. Put that
down. You have to say, put that down.
Put that down.
There you go. Okay. You ready
for your, would you rather? Yes.
You have to pay attention. Now I'm
listening. Okay. Would you rather, okay.
I wear a diaper and I poe and Ip in
the diver and you have to change me.
Oh,
like Ellis,
you have to change me in addition
to Ellis every day, the other thing,
whatever it is,
or every meal you eat,
I have to put it in a blender and puree
it first like baby food and you have to
eat that. That's how you eat for
the rest of your life. Question.
Yeah. [inaudible] sure.
Hey, my fucking food man.
But I'm hearing pizza.
I'm pure Ria and cheeseburgers
all never like it ever again.
You'll never enjoy eating.
I have total care. I'll take the puree.
My eyes are watering. Thinking about it.
I feel like it's vomit or something like
that. My diaper know about the purees.
I was water weight. But
you take that. Yeah.
I don't want to fucking
change your diaper. You're,
I smell what comes out of
you and I want to see it. Oh,
I'm calling you and then like,
hey babe,
you want to have sex and
we take your diaper off.
Make sure you haven't
shit in it. No. Yeah,
I'm just like one of those fetish people.
Like I'm a big baby.
You have to change my diet. I, and Oh,
you want me to puree all your food
forever. Hundred thousand percent. Okay.
What about you? What would you choose? Um,
I would change your diaper. I feel like,
I feel like the same thing I've already
smelled and seeing everything. Who Cares?
Like, I'm already changing
shit diapers every day.
I enjoy eating too much
to puree everything
you would do it. What wouldn't
you change? My Dad died.
No, I'm saying I would change
your diet. Oh, you would? Yeah,
I'm saying I would prefer that to pureeing
everything I ever eat cause I enjoy
eating too much. Your Shits are
disgusting and Sword Ellis'.
I just wipe it up and move on. I have
to get a much bigger diaper. Genie.
You probably start trimming
the hair back there too,
because it makes it clean up way alone.
Trimming your hair.
Change my trimming my butthole hair. Yeah,
that's true. I never thought of that.
We're going to have to get you waxed
for sure and then I would put it off.
I haven't done it. I know. Now we'll
just make sure that you do that.
We do want to hear some submitted
ones. The came, Nick said,
would you rather have horrendous,
nasty sewer mouth that everyone around
you can smell where whenever they're
around you or everyone around
you has putrid, wicked,
bad breath.
It only you can smell.
So either everyone's smelling bad breath
or you're smelling everyone else's bad
breath. I'd rather smell everyone else's
and be the source of misery. Oh man,
that's rough. I just had an
Uber ride and I sat up front.
I was with my cousin and her husband.
And have you ever had that where you could
smell the driver's breath from across
the other seat and you're
like, Jesus man. Yeah,
I feel like someone shit in your mouth.
They know wafts over every fear
is not crack the window just to,
and I leaned my head out just a brief.
I kind of like feels
shitty smelly dog mount.
Like it smells like a fish market,
but I kinda like it. I don't know why.
Cause he's just so sweet.
What would you choose?
I think I would have to just be shit
mouth. You'd be the ship mouth? Yeah.
Oh,
but then what about us and our
marriage? We you don't care. No, I do.
But you just fight through
it, man. I have to suffer.
You're basically saying that I have to
suffer. I don't suffer. It's terrible.
You don't choose me over you suffering.
That's not love.
What do you mean this though?
I'm choosing to smell everyone else's so
that I don't make other people suffer.
You're choosing to make
other people suffer by being
the source of their misery.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, that's not true. I'm just,
I just don't want to smell
anyone else's bad breath.
They'll be so harsh
about it. Selfish. Yeah.
Here's one other one that
came in that one, by the way,
that I say who was from that
was from nick. This is a,
would you rather have a 10 inch painter,
but you can only have sex
once a year or for 30 days.
You have to shit out of
10 inch.
Super from log once an hour.
That's 24 10 inch shifts a day for 30
days. Jesus. So many variables in years.
It's, um, I don't, I can't follow it.
That was Greg too complicated. Okay.
Can I do mine? Yeah. A professional.
Would you rather? Okay. Okay.
You Ready? I'm listening.
And this is tailored to you,
so you need to pay attention
to this. Okay. Watch. Okay.
Would you rather have to listen to your
dad's stories over and over and he tells
the same five. Okay. And then, yeah,
I'd tell you about the
time and I'm really ready.
I think a kind of ready to dial it back.
Okay.
Getting ready to retire. Okay. Yeah.
So you have to listen to your dad,
tell the stories,
the same stories or you
have to tell the same jokes.
Oh, well I just going to
reality for the next 10 years.
Three Allity is already number one.
Yeah.
Reality is I'm living in that.
There's not a thing like, hey,
what would it be like if my dad told
the same stories? That's what happened.
But I mean, you're all all day, every day.
Your option is the only communication you
have with somebody is with your father
and he tells you the same stories.
I'm getting better at
processing my emotions when
he does tell the same stories.
So I would do that because I know I can't
do the same job for 10 years, you know,
it's torn them over about
horrible, whatever, every 16
months. I just did it done.
How do you think these poor musicians
have to staff to sing the same?
Goddamn do Margaritaville and you're like,
I think it's kind of more fun for them to
perform songs. Maybe. Maybe. Yeah. Okay.
Well let those thoughts what I have.
That's good genes. That's good. I like it.
Not It, um, anything else? No. All right.
We have a, uh, a closing
song that came in sound.
It's from Yeltsin and uh,
Pedro, it's what y'all do. The five page.
Oh, I'd do a pie. A Patriot and thing.
Sorry. Hydrea that's where we have
blue band here. Put that down.
What do we have to do? It's going to
be right at the top. It's at the top.
Shout out. Oh yeah. All
right. Closing Song.
Our patrion shout outs are Mark
O'malley Pammy be Bill Gunn,
solace,
John Bronson and Amanda Pearson.
Big shout out to you guys.
Thank you for being patrons on Patrion.
Put that down.
Now the song,
uh,
listening to my guys,
my mommies,
it's
bad.
We got the top
yet your Mama's house and
with debt bomb ass crew,
Christina was to which to cut. She's
got the brains teased about that. Fr.
Bron Tj, dad, Bob says to the stem,
carry your pitch. Cooking chicken can
change this teaching deletion painted now.
I'm hoping you'll listen.
Radio television depletion painted now.
Oh,
great.
That's
good.